Moon Knight ist einer der
unbekannteren Marvel-Charaktere.
Aber er verspricht jetzt schon
alle Rekorde zu brechen.
Der 1. Trailer
der Disney-Serie schlug hohe Wellen.
Das liegt nicht nur an der Action,
dem düsteren Look
und dem psychologischen Tiefgang.
Es liegt auch an der Starbesetzung.
Hi, ich bin Oscar Isaac.
Willkommen zu "Science vs. Fiction".
Hallo zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Ich freue mich sehr
auf die neue "Moon Knight"-Serie.
Die ersten 4 Folgen
durfte ich vorab sehen.
Ich bin hyped,
wie es weitergeht.
Vor allem weil Marvel
keinen typischen Superhelden zeigt.
Es geht nicht nur
um Mut, Kraft und Stärke.
Wir erleben einen Charakter
mit psychischen Schwierigkeiten.
Was bist du?
Lebst du in mir?
Es ist komplizierter.
Was ist genau mit ihm los?
Wie realistisch
ist es in der Serie dargestellt?
Das besprechen wir
mit Psychologin Mareike Thomas.
Sie arbeitet
an der Universität Halle.
Sie promovierte
in der medizinischen Psychologie.
Sie war schon mal bei uns zu Gast.
Da ging es
um Stalking und Narzissmus.
Über Moon Knight hat sie
bislang nur mit Patienten gesprochen.
Schön, dass du da bist.
- Hallo, ich freue mich auch.
Wir haben schon über Joe
aus der Netflix Serie You gesprochen.
Jetzt reden wir über Moon Knight.
Wir tauschen das Bücherregal
gegen das ägyptische Museum.
Wir Fragen heute:
Was ist mit ihm los?
Ich glaube,
es wird ziemlich spannend.
Aber wichtig vorab:
Wir sprechen
über Traumata und Folgestörungen.
Falls ihr Probleme
in dem Bereich habt,
bitte die Folge
nicht alleine schauen.
Bevor wir uns in die Tiefen
der menschlichen Psyche vorwagen,
gibt es Hintergrundinformationen
für alle,
die Moon Knight nicht kennen.
Wir haben
den Kanal Nerdfactory gefragt.
Die haben
einen Backgroundcheck gemacht.
Luke, was gab es
in der Comic-Welt zu erfahren?
Hey, ich fasse zusammen,
was wir aus den Comics wissen.
Er heißt
im richtigen Leben Marc Spector.
Er ist Sohn eines Rabbis,
der vor den Nazis
aus der Tschechoslowakei
in die USA floh.
Doch auch dort erlebte die Familie
immer wieder Diskriminierung.
Marc wollte sich als Kind wehren,
arbeitete im Laufe seines Lebens
bei der Marine,
der CIA und als Söldner.
Er weiß also mit Waffen umzugehen
und ist im Nahkampf sehr gefährlich.
Er entwickelt mit der Zeit
verschiedene Persönlichkeiten.
Etwa die
des Finanzmannes Steven Grant
und des Taxifahrers Jake Lockley.
Das ist also anders
als in der neuen Serie.
Als er sich tödlich verletzt,
schenkt ihm
der ägyptische Gott Khonshu
das Leben.
Im Gegenzug
wird Marc Spector
als Moon Knight zu dessen Diener.
Danke Luke.
Wenn wir die verschiedenen
Persönlichkeiten sehen,
könnte man auf den Gedanken kommen,
dass es mit Schizophrenie zu tun hat.
Ist das plausibel?
Das ist nicht so weit weg davon.
Bei der Schizophrenie haben wir auch
akustische Halluzinationen,
wie wir es bei Marvel sehen.
Geh wieder schlafen Wurm.
Du sollst hier nicht sein.
Wo sind Sie?
- Übergebe den Körper an Marc.
Den Körper ...
Welcher Körper?
*Er seufzt*
Idioten in Kontrolle.
Bei Schizophrenie liegt meist
eine organische Ursache vor.
Die verschiedenen Persönlichkeiten,
auch bekannt als
multiple Persönlichkeitsstörung,
geht häufig
mit akustischem Stimmenhören einher.
Wobei das verschiedene
Persönlichkeitsanteile sind.
In der Fachsprache sprechen wir
von dissoziativer Identitätsstörung.
Die zeichnet sich vor allem
durch Gedächtnislücken aus,
wie wir es in der Serie auch sehen.
Was wir auch sehen, ist,
dass uns im Trailer Marc Spector
als jemand anderes vorgestellt wird.
Nämlich als Steven.
Und Steven weiß nichts von Marc.
Der hat
ein Problem mit Schlafstörungen.
Hallo,
willkommen bei Staying Awake.
Ich habe eine Schlafstörung.
Ich kann keinen Unterschied
zwischen wach und träumen erkennen.
Es geht sogar so weit,
dass er sich ans Bett kettet,
um zu überprüfen,
ob er schlafwandelt.
Ist es plausibel,
dass die Persönlichkeiten
nichts voneinander wissen?
Ja, das ist oft so.
Die Persönlichkeiten
existieren nebeneinander,
haben verschiedene
Charaktere und Eigenschaften.
Manchmal haben sie auch
verschiedene Sehstärken.
So weit geht das.
Oft weiß eine Person
von der anderen nichts.
Dadurch entstehen Gedächtnislücken.
In der Psychologie sprechen wir
von dissoziativer Amnesie.
Das ist ein wichtiges Kernkriterium,
um die Krankheit zu diagnostizieren.
Solche Amnesien gibt es
auch bei anderen Erkrankungen.
Da sprachen wir
in der Folge zum Joker drüber.
Da ging es um
posttraumatische Belastungsstörungen.
Da war das auch Thema.
Sowohl PTBS
als auch
dissoziative Identitätsstörungen
kann man
als Traumafolgestörung beschreiben.
Bei PTBS
können auch Amnesien auftreten,
aber auch
andere dissoziative Zustände.
Die Betroffenen sind dann
nicht wirklich im Hier und Jetzt.
Sie haben auch Flashbacks.
Bei dissoziativer Identitätsstörung
ist es so,
dass die Betroffenen
als Reaktion auf das Trauma
Persönlichkeitsanteile ausbilden.
Sie können die nicht integrieren
in eine einheitliche
oder kohärente Persönlichkeit.
Es ist wie ein Schutzmechanismus.
Ich stelle es mir schwer vor,
das als Schauspieler darzustellen.
Ich konnte im Vorfeld
ein Interview mit Oscar Isaac führen.
Der gab mir Einblicke.
Er hatte zur Vorbereitung
ein Buch von Robert Oxnam gelesen.
Der war Diplomat in der US-Regierung
unter Bill Clinton.
Er hat selber
eine dissoziative Identitätsstörung.
Was Oscar Isaac daran bewegt hat
und was er damit verbindet,
erzählte er mir im Interview.
Eine der Sachen ist,
dass es
ein organisierendes Prinzip gibt.
Menschen mit einer
dissoziativen Identitätsstörung
haben ein Organisierungsprinzip.
Es kann ein Labyrinth
oder ein Schloss sein,
wo die Persönlichkeiten leben.
Sie haben eigene Territorien.
Was wir sehen konnten,
klingt, als hätte Oxnam sich
in therapeutische
Behandlung begeben.
Er hat wohl
eine Bewältigungsstrategie
für die Problematik entwickelt.
Man muss dazu sagen,
dass sich das Störungsbild
sehr heterogen zeigt.
Es ist bei jedem Betroffenen anders.
Häufig ist es so,
dass die Persönlichkeiten
nichts voneinander wissen.
Die Persönlichkeiten
sind nicht unbedingt gleichgestellt.
Sie kommen im Alltag
unterschiedlich gut klar.
Manche sind funktional.
Manche verletzen sich evtl. selbst.
Es gibt auch Kinderpersönlichkeiten.
Ach echt?
Das finde ich krass.
Dass die Persönlichkeiten
unterschiedlich viel
voneinander wissen,
sehen wir deutlich im Trailer.
Während Marc alles über Steven weiß,
weiß Steven nichts über Marc.
Ja?
- Was stimmt mit dir nicht, Marc?
Warum hast du mich Marc genannt?
Das kann so passieren.
Man muss sagen,
dass wir in der Forschung
noch nicht so weit sind,
was das Störungsbild angeht.
Häufig wird in den Studien
mit Einzelfällen gearbeitet.
Das liegt darin begründet,
dass die Störung selten auftritt.
Sie wird medial häufig aufgegriffen.
Ich denke an Filme
wie Split oder Fight Club.
Wenn du sagst, selten,
was heißt das genau?
Im Endeffekt
bei ca. 1% der Bevölkerung.
1 von 100.
Das klingt für mich nicht so selten.
Wenn man das mit Erkrankungen
wie Depression vergleicht,
sprechen wir von etwa 16-20%,
Angststörungen liegen bei etwa 28%.
Das ist ein krasser Unterschied.
Wir haben viel
über die Krankheit gesprochen.
Aber wenig darüber,
wie die entsteht.
Was sind die Ursachen?
Bist du sicher,
dass du es wissen willst?
Das muss sehr schwer sein.
Es ängstigt dich.
Oft entsteht das Störungsbild
schon in der Kindheit.
In der Entwicklung müssen Kinder
verschiedene Informationen
von verschiedenen Seiten
integrieren können.
Sie müssen sie
unter einen Hut bekommen.
In der Erziehung ist es so,
dass eine Mutter auch mal böse
und nicht nur liebevoll ist.
Kinder kriegen
in der Regel erklärt,
warum das so ist
und ab und zu auch so sein muss.
Sie verstehen dann auch,
dass Mama 2 Seiten hat.
Häufig ist es
bei dieser Erkrankung aber so,
dass schwerwiegendere Ereignisse
aufgetreten sind.
Die Kinder können sie
nicht gut verarbeiten
und bekommen sie nicht
in eine Persönlichkeit integriert.
Etwas Traumatisierendes,
was sie erlebt haben.
Ja, genau.
Da der Begriff Trauma
heute inflationär verwendet wird,
ist es wichtig,
eine Definition zu geben.
Das meint
das Erleben oder die Zeugenschaft
eines erheblichen Traumas
in Form einer Konfrontation
mit tatsächlichem
oder drohendem Tod,
einer ernsthaften Verletzung
oder sexueller Gewalt.
Bei der
dissoziativen Identitätsstörung
ist es dann kritisch,
wenn die missbrauchende Person
eine nahe Bezugsperson ist.
Für Kinder ist es dann schwierig,
das unter einen Hut zu bekommen.
Bei etwa 90% der Betroffenen
ist es so,
dass in der Kindheit
körperlicher, sexueller
oder emotionaler Missbrauch vorlag.
Auch emotionale Vernachlässigung
ist ein wichtiges Thema.
Bei den restlichen Personen
ist es häufig so,
dass ein anderes
schweres Trauma erlitten wurde.
Etwa der Tod eines nahen Angehörigen
oder ein Unfall.
Ob das bei Moon Knight der Fall ist,
kann nur einer beantworten.
Luke, sag mal,
hat Marc Spector als Kind
etwas Traumatisches
in die Richtung erlebt?
In den Comics sehen wir,
dass Marc als Kind herausfindet,
dass ein Freund der Familie,
ebenfalls ein Rabbi,
ein ehemaliger Nazi-Offizier
und Serienmörder vieler Juden ist.
Marc musste Schreckliches mitansehen
und greift den Rabbi an.
Der verschwindet spurlos.
Aber bei Marc
bleibt ein
immenses psychisches Trauma.
Ab da hat Marc
eine zweite Persönlichkeit,
die von Jake Lockley.
Die Krankheit wird immer schlimmer,
sein Leben gerät außer Kontrolle.
Fairerweise muss man sagen:
Es ist nicht sein letztes Trauma.
So wird seine Geliebte
von seinem Bruder
mit einer Axt ermordet.
What the fuck?
Das ist eine heftige Geschichte.
Wir können festhalten,
dass es sich um ein Trauma handelt,
das Marc Spector
in seiner Kindheit erleben musste.
Wie wir gerade von Luke hörten,
wird die Krankheit, die Marc hat,
in den Comics immer schlimmer.
Ist es in der echten Welt plausibel,
dass immer mehr
Persönlichkeiten dazu kommen?
Prinzipiell ist es
ohne Behandlung nicht unüblich.
Wir haben alle verschiedene
Persönlichkeitsanteile in uns.
Schwierig wird, wenn sich
daraus eigene Identitäten bilden.
Das kann passieren,
indem wir etwa ein Kind haben,
dem was Furchtbares widerfahren ist.
Diese Erinnerungen
können sich abkapseln.
Um die Abkapselung
entsteht eine eigene Persönlichkeit.
Verschiedene Persönlichkeiten
können sich so entfalten:
Etwa ein unbeschwertes Kind,
eine Beschützerpersönlichkeit,
aber auch "Täterintrojekte".
Das bedeutet,
dass sich das Kind unbewusst
mit dem Angreifer identifiziert.
Es entstehen Gedanken, wie:
"Dass etwas Furchtbares passierte,
geschieht dir recht.
Du hast es nicht anders verdient."
Solche Feinde im Inneren
können fördern,
dass die Persönlichkeit
in immer mehr Anteile zerbricht.
Das klingt gruselig.
Das erinnert mich an einen Beitrag
von unseren Kollegen von "Die Frage".
Da hat Frank eine Frau getroffen.
Sie hatte sehr deutlich
viele verschiedene
Persönlichkeiten in sich drin.
Also ich bin viele.
Hallo.
*Sie lacht*
Ich spiele gerne viel.
Magst du ein Eis?
Wenn jetzt alle darüber reden,
muss sich auch was dazu sagen.
Hallo.
- Ich bin Bart, check.
Da ging es mir
etwas komisch beim Zuschauen.
Es war eine ungewohnte Art,
wie so etwas gelebt wird.
Ja, es ist auffällig gewesen,
dass die Betroffene sehr bewusst
hin und her switchen konnte
zwischen den Persönlichkeiten.
Ich möchte ihr das nicht absprechen.
Vielleicht hat sie das
in einer Therapie gelernt.
In der Regel ist es eher so,
dass verschiedene Persönlichkeiten
durch Situationen
oder Reize getriggert werden.
Die kommen unbewusst zum Vorschein.
Steven.
- Hallo, Mann im Spiegel.
Ich weiß,
dass du Angst hast
und verwirrt bist.
Du solltest das nicht sehen.
Was ich sehr spannend fand,
ist, dass die Persönlichkeit,
die nicht vordergründig aktiv ist,
sondern im Hintergrund ist,
den Zustand als isoliert
und eingeschlossen beschreibt.
Ist das etwas, was stattfindet?
Das wird
von Betroffenen zu Betroffenen
unterschiedlich sein.
Aber je mehr Persönlichkeiten
voneinander untereinander wissen,
umso weniger Erinnerungslücken
wird es geben.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass die Persönlichkeiten
sich untereinander
aus der Vogelperspektive beobachten.
Marvel hat
einen cleveren Kniff draus gemacht.
Sie haben Spiegelsequenzen eingebaut,
wo die Persönlichkeiten
sich im Spiegelbild beobachten.
Ich kann uns retten.
Du sollst mich nicht bekämpfen.
Du musst mir Kontrolle geben.
Nein!
- Schau mich an, ich bin real.
Nein, das bist du nicht!
Lass mich uns retten.
Ich stelle mir das
als abgefahrene Erfahrung vor.
Ich kann mir das schwer vorstellen.
Das ist auch der Grund,
warum ich mich beim Schauen der Doku
fast ein bisschen
schlecht gefühlt habe.
Weil man schon Restzweifel hat,
ob das alles authentisch ist.
Das ging auch der Expertenwelt so.
Schuld ist ein Fall
aus den 1970er Jahren.
Eine Psychiaterin
hat ein Buch veröffentlicht
über eine Patientin Shirley Mason
mit angeblich 16 Persönlichkeiten.
Es gab ein kleines Kind,
dass sich Oma nannte.
Es gab einen Jungen namens Mike.
Es gab Vicky und Peggy Ann.
Ihr Buch "Sybil"
verkaufte sich mehr als 6 Mio. Mal.
Nenn mich Sweetie.
Der Fernsehfilm wurde ein Hit.
Er verwandelte
die Geschichte in eine Sensation.
Daraufhin
meldeten sich viele Amerikaner.
Die beschrieben,
dass es ihnen
wie der Patientin im Buch geht.
Man fand heraus,
dass die Psychiaterin
die Patientin zu Aussagen brachte,
um Profit aus der Sache zu schlagen.
Dr. Wilbur suchte nach Traumata.
Sie hatte die Vorstellung,
dass Shirley
etwas Schreckliches widerfahren war.
Sie wusste nicht, was es war.
Also wurde sie
rücksichtslos befragt.
Etwa über Dinge,
die ihre Mutter
mit ihr gemacht haben könnte.
Mit vielen Suggestivfragen.
Das klingt
nach einer Spitzentherapeutin.
Kann man ausschließen, dass Patienten
sich das nur einbilden
oder ob sie simulieren?
Vorab: Dass es die Erkrankung gibt,
ist definitiv bewiesen.
Wir sehen es sogar im Gehirn.
Ich habe eine Studie mitgebracht
von der Cambridge University.
Dort schaute man sich 2015
die Gehirne von 75 Frauen an.
Es hatten sich nur Frauen
freiwillig bereit erklärt.
32 davon hatten
eine dissoziative Identitätsstörung.
45 hatten keine.
Von deren Gehirnen
hat man MRT-Aufnahmen gemacht.
Man hat gemessen,
wie groß die Teile
des Hippocampus sind.
Der Bereich des Gehirns
ist für Erinnerungen zuständig.
Man konnte belegen,
dass dieser Bereich des Gehirns
bei Menschen
mit dissoziativer Identitätsstörung
deutlich kleiner ist
als bei Menschen ohne diese Störung.
D.h., das Gehirn arbeitet anders?
Genau das funktioniert anders.
2012 gab es eine Studie
vom Kings College in London.
Forschende verglichen mit Hirnscans
die Hirnaktivität von 11 Menschen
mit dissoziativer Identitätsstörung,
mit denen von 18,
die nicht betroffen waren.
Die sollten
Persönlichkeitswechsel imitieren.
Die Hirnscans
waren komplett unterschiedlich.
Auch bei denen,
die sich viel Mühe gaben.
Nicht einmal
professionelle Schauspieler
konnten die Rollen
so glaubhaft verkörpern,
dass die Hirnscans ähnlich aussahen.
Der Wechsel der Persönlichkeiten
betrifft nicht nur
das vordergründige Gebaren.
Es werden verschiedene
neuronale Netze im Gehirn aktiviert.
Reize werden anders verarbeitet.
Aber auch Prozesse im Körper
wie der Puls
und der Blutdruck,
aber auch Sehschärfe
können variieren.
Die sind also unterschiedlich
von Persönlichkeit zu Persönlichkeit.
Das ist total irre.
Ich finde es megaspannend.
Jetzt haben wir das Problem,
dass wir nicht bei jeder Diagnose
noch einen Hirnscan machen können.
Ja, das ist schwierig.
Das machen wir in Therapien anders.
Wir holen uns Informationen
von außerhalb, etwa Angehörige, ein.
Das machen wir,
um Ungereimtheiten aufzudecken.
Es gibt ein paar auffällige Sachen
bei simulierenden Personen.
Sie neigen eher dazu,
Aspekte der Störung
überdeutlich zu präsentieren.
Andere Aspekte
zeigen sie dagegen gar nicht.
Häufig ist es auch so,
dass Simulierende es so darstellen,
als sei es etwas Tolles.
Sie finden teilweise Gefallen darin,
Persönlichkeiten zu wechseln.
Betroffene
empfinden es eher als unangenehm.
Sie versuchen
die Störung zu verstecken.
Ich habe
meine Kontaktlinsen verloren.
Ich hoffe, Sie finden sie.
Moon Knight handelt
trotz seiner Krankheit als Held.
Mareike, wie gehen Betroffene
in der Realität mit der Störung um?
An Heldentaten ist nicht zu denken.
Die Betroffenen
sind häufig depressiv und ängstlich.
Sie leiden etwa
unter sexuellen Funktionsstörungen.
Betroffene von Missbrauch neigen
zu selbstzerstörerischem Verhalten,
Selbstverletzung und Substanzkonsum.
Aber sie neigen auch manchmal dazu,
Risiken oder risikohafte Situationen
häufig aufzusuchen
oder ihnen nicht zu entgehen.
Man kann auch
von "risk seeking" sprechen.
Das sehen wir auch bei Marc Spector.
Er scheut keinen Konflikt
und teilt ordentlich aus.
Er begibt sich in Gefahr.
Er arbeitete
für die CIA und als Söldner.
Aber die Frage ist,
gibt es für ihn eine Alternative?
Gibt es Wege aus dieser Störung?
Für Betroffene ist es wichtig,
eine Psychotherapie zu machen.
Das Ziel ist,
die Persönlichkeiten
in eine kohärente Persönlichkeit
zu integrieren.
Da geht es auch darum,
Bewältigungsstrategien
für die Probleme,
die im Alltag auftreten, zu lernen.
Wichtig ist auch,
je früher eine Therapie ansetzt,
umso besser für den Verlauf.
Die Begleitsymptome
wie Depression und Angst
können auch
medikamentös mitbehandelt werden.
Ob Moon Knight sich
in so eine Art von Therapie begibt,
kann ich noch nicht sagen.
Im Trailer
sehen wir eine Art Nervenklinik.
Es bleibt spannend
und ich verspreche,
es gibt einige Plot-Twists,
die sich auf jeden Fall lohnen.
Deswegen hauen wir
noch einmal die Nerdfactory an.
Luke, mach uns noch
ein bisschen Bock auf die Serie.
Die Serie ist actionreich.
Wir erfahren im Laufe der Folgen
immer mehr
über die verschiedenen Charaktere:
Steven Grant,
Marc Spector und Khonshu und Co.
Es ist sehr actionreich,
aber es ist auch ein tiefer Einblick
in die Psyche dieses Menschen
mit der Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Es war Oscar Isaac als Produzent
und Hauptdarsteller wichtig,
dass die Krankheit
gut dargestellt wird.
Ich denke,
das ist ihm auch gelungen.
Mareike, Danke fürs Erklären.
- Sehr gerne.
Ich finde es großartig,
dass Marvel das bei der Serie
in den Fokus stellt
und dass psychische Störungen
in so einer Serie Platz finden.
Was denkt ihr?
Sollte das häufiger
in der fiktionalen Welt vorkommen?
Oscar Isaac zeigte mir im Interview
eine deutliche Haltung dazu.
Darum ist es schon immer gegangen,
schon bei
antiken griechischen Stücken.
Bevor wir eine Vorstellung
von PTSB hatten,
kamen Soldaten ins Theater
und durchlebten ihre Erfahrungen,
um eine Katharsis zu erzeugen.
Es ging beim Schauspiel immer darum,
Leuten dabei zu helfen,
mit Problemen des Lebens umzugehen.
Das Interview mit Oscar Isaac
haben wir separat hochgeladen.
Den Link findet ihr in der Infobox.
Genauso wie den Link
zu Lukes Kanal, der Nerdfactory.
Vielen Dank
für die Hintergrundinformationen.
Wenn euch das Video gefällt,
freue ich mich,
wenn ihr Kommentare dalasst
und einen Daumen nach oben gebt.
Vergesst nicht, diesen Kanal zu ...
... abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann können wir uns wiedersehen.
Ich würde mich freuen, bis dahin.
Wie nennt Marvel es eigentlich,
wenn Marc Spector
jemanden im Club abschleppt?
Es ist ein Moon Knight Stand.
*Er lacht*
Copyright UT: MDR 2022
Wollte ich noch mal kurz ...
*räusper*